her weight before to her weight now good
point like so is she not perceived in a
different way is she not treated
differently
but then it's not privileged though it's
more like she's being treated like it's
it's like that's it's the norm right
it's like yeah so so how okay
even while she had had a lot of weight
on the you know the body positivity
positivity movement was in there trying
like propping her up and everybody you
know
the movement's been around since like
2012. yeah around for a long time about
2012 i don't think is a long time to be
honest but um
so she's lost weight now and people are
praising them but she was also getting a
lot of hate from a lot of the people in
the body positivity movement who were
who looked at her and saw that okay
maybe the method she's trying to send to
other women is not um
uh a good one in that she's losing
weight she it's like
that whole movement it's it's just an
agenda like it's like
why not see that this person has worked
in the gym eating eating healthy to lose
weight to make yourself look more
attractive and able to make yourself
look healthier right wouldn't they be
more positive to say that that would
like that's the positive aspect of her
losing weight right
rather than looking at and saying okay
she's lost weight now a lot of these
girls are going to want to lose weight
as well like what's wrong with but also
sorry i thought the body positivity um
movement um on
the basis of it was the acceptance of
all body types yeah well you kind of we
should like you like
why should we accept all body types for
women because
because
because because it's unhealthy yeah but
it's something like it's not a choice
it's not as simple as that what do you
mean
no no no no no no no no it's yeah it's
one
say that again i said it's not always a
choice it's not a choice what you put in
your mouth look at pictures from the
1950s 1940s 1930s 1920s girls did not
look like this what's the difference
it's eating in countries where there's
famine
in countries where there's famine do you
see people morbidly obese
okay i think we're being extreme no no
no it's a good question it's a good
question because no do you know why i'm
asking because if it was something that
comes about it just happened i didn't
choose to gain this weight you would see
in countries where people don't have
food yeah yet you don't so what does
that say
okay and that's a fair enough point i do
feel like we're being a little extreme
because girls can i can put on weight if
i just decide to change my contraception
yes but however it's a choice however
not even just that not just that like
let's say you couldn't you couldn't um
choose you have to take it right usually
if you're taking less calories then
you're sorry if you're taking less if
you're burning more calories then you're
taking it in yeah you will lose weight
right so that just means that you you're
not um but i think the issue what i the
issue that i'm having with what you're
saying is that you're making it heavily
seem like it's a choice you're you're
fat because you want to be because it is
no but you might not want to be as a
consequence of your actions yeah like
how is it not a consequence of your
actions if you eat more you gain weight
just quickly
i i suffered from an eating disorder for
many years
so when i went into an eating disorder
clinic that was i was surrounded by
people who not only suffered from
anorexia bulimia but also binge eating
disorder and i can tell you for a fact
that is not a choice
but like we're not talking about that
we're talking about people that are
obese yeah no i'm talking about people
who are obese but if you look at them
you don't know what is happening behind
the scenes and that is you can't be
obese and have an eating disorder yes
you can it's binge eating disorder it's
well then you're eating yeah yeah you
are eating but it's emotional
okay okay fine fine fine you could say
they eat too much
mental health it's emotional eating okay
do you think that eighty percent of
people in america have uh binge eating
disorder then
god damn i i do think that probably the
percentage of people in america with
disorder is a lot higher
yeah i'm not saying saying 80 of people
in the in the usa do but i suspect a lot
more people in the usa if you look at
statistics maybe let's look at some
statistics
probably a lot more people in the us do
than in the uk the obesity um i actually
did look this up so out of the ages of
24 to 25 to 34 23 in the uk are obese
35 are overweight and 42 percent are
normal and
i can't it's so small the underweight
category that i can't even see it so
even in the uk but you can equally have
people who are of a healthy bmi that
actually have a very unhealthy
relationship with food
so yes i mean you can you can have a
good bmi and
eat bad foods yes yeah yeah that's
possible but it's still a choice the
foods you put in your body are a choice
but
we're trying to make excuses for people
not eating right like we can't keep on
doing that yeah i don't think it's
excuses but i just i can't i don't think
i can agree how heavily we're putting it
on the fact that it's a choice but this
is what this is but this is what women
do like honestly anytime a man has a
standard we shame them for it and take
accountability away from women
no and this is this is i'm not saying
specifically you right but i'm saying in
general like the men say they want thin
girls or in shape girls and then the
body positivity movement comes there's
no but i'm saying there's no there's no
broke man positivity
yeah because it doesn't exist like we
take away accountability from women's
poor choices and even now like when
we're talking about hey it's a choice if
you eat too much and you gain weight
yeah it's like we're taking
accountability away from the woman by
saying it's not a choice but even it
doesn't have to be sorry
even within the context of bodies right
if i'm i was born six foot so i'm i'm
happy i'm good but you were born sick
sorry
genetically i was
i was genetically predisposed to be six
foot cool but if i wasn't if i was born
if i was meant to be five foot there is
no one here that would say to me women
should love you anyway women should go
for yourself women should find you
attractive today you should you might
say that but most women won't so i think
so date a fat guy
i have
would you and
where is where is he now where is he now
i understand we have money back where i
left it
i think i understand what you're saying
you're like there are some people for
example who might emotionally eat yeah
right so
we can we can say we understand why they
made the decisions they did in those
moments right because it may be to cope
with something right right so it's not
saying that we can't have compassion for
why they made those choices but at the
end of the day they did make those
choices yes right and that's what they
are worthy of love
no one is saying that they're not worthy
of love
and privilege is that maybe a thinner
woman would be well here's the thing i i
when it comes to thin privilege i think
it actually comes down to
beauty or attractive privilege because
chances are most people will probably
find you more attractive if you're on
the slimmer side than if you're obese so
you think it's a thing of attractiveness
and pretty privileged little not
necessarily well being being thin or
being being thin or being slim is a
contributing factor to how attractive
some people find you that's just the way
it is so who okay do you know what so as
pick a celebrity that you would say a
female celebrity that you would say
you're attracted to that megan good
right if megan good
was a size 20 tomorrow how big is that i
don't know how big it is
that's like all the deals
that's bigger
that's big what we're talking about
she's she's obese she's obese okay she's
obese it's affected every part of her
from her knees heads and face everything
okay cool
would that would that suddenly change
your level of attraction to her you just
said it's a contributing factor so of
course yeah it's not just the looks it's
the self-respect
let me answer your questions